okay uh
it's my great honor to introduce our
speaker this morning
oh okay come here
yeah so it's my great honor to introduce
our speaker uh this morning Dr Sarah
senior scientist and project leader
decision applications division at the
Los Alamos National Laboratory
she does amazing work on combining
internet data with satellite imagery to
forecast to this outbreak she does a lot
of really exciting exciting work in
mathematical epidemiology
so she got her PhD from University of
Iowa under the supervision of Harvard
health code and Mark Hyman 2005 and then
went to Los Alamos ever since and she's
won many awards I will highlight the one
she got just last few days ago like last
week or something and it's a Global
Security medal which is one of the
highest honors given that the love which
recognizes the exceptional achievements
of active and and recently retired
employees who have made outstanding
contributions to the to the lab
the global
security mission of the lab so she won
the Medal a few days ago so it's a great
honor to to have Sarah join us remotely
and present her lecture and I by the
screen over the
title
okay yeah it says Global comparison of
covid-19 varied waves and relationships
is clinical and demographic factors
thank you sir
um thank you so much Abba for the
introduction
um
um I'm sorry that I'm not there in
person but I am I I've watched some of
the videos and I think a lot of the
discussions have been really fruitful
and and interesting and um
and so I'm really looking forward to to
hearing more about
um what's happening today
so this is a project that we are we have
started and so I don't know if I'm going
to be using a full hour and so I think
there's also a lot of opportunity for
feedback but um we've been looking at
sequencing data and now I'll go into
more detail during my presentation but
uh basically the the goal is to enter in
to kind of exploit this data and and
hopefully will help us with our
forecasting efforts
so um I wanted to start with a short
introduction about our
um our goal and our vision and why we
feel we need sequencing data
um as many of you know epidemic
forecasting has kind of started to play
a key role in not just during the
covid-19 pandemic response but uh for
the last
um 10 12 years
um after the h21 pandemic the CDC kind
of began to
figure out the fact that you know they
just didn't want models to understand
and assess the impact of mitigation
strategies but they also wanted to
forecast
um infectious diseases and so they've
been doing a lot of forecasting
initiatives from uh for flu zika
Chikungunya denge
um and and some other diseases and so
that kind of provided the foundation for
uh covet and so when covid um
uh emerge then there were a lot of
groups that were already doing kind of
forecasting and so including our group
here at Los Angeles participated in the
flu forecasting and some other
forecasting challenges for the CDC so
there's been a lot of forecasting
um models uh that can forecast cases
that's hospitalizations but but only if
you have actually Incorporated sequences
and if um so here if you if you look at
the the figure that I included on my
slide and this is a figure from Nick
Wright and others on the predictability
of covert 19.
um they demonstrated that there were
many instances during the covid-19
pandemic where the models were
completely
um off and the accuracy was very low and
so I've kind of highlighted two major
um areas and that's uh the first one is
when the delta
um variant emerge and so most of the
models you know because there was a
significant decrease in number of cases
most of the models
um were forecasting that a number of
cases we're going to continue to to kind
of either stay in the steady state or
um or decline but we still have a very
steep Rising number of cases and also
there's been you know other cases where
when new variants have emerged
um the models haven't really been able
to incorporate that change
um and and so that's that's one of the
major limitations and so our hypothesis
and what we're currently trying to do is
um see how we can incorporate sequencing
information so that we can ultimately
improve disease forecasting
um and increase the accuracy and right
now I'm only gonna be focusing on the um
we're kind of just analyzing sequencing
data and we're kind of trying to
understand how
um it will inform forecasting efforts we
still haven't gotten to the forecasting
part and so I'm just going to kind of
walk you through some of the analysis
that we're currently doing
and so here's a
um a schematic representation or
cartoonia representation of what we feel
uh we want to do
um so we have this sequencing data that
is the first
um the first kind of box here of um that
I'm I'm showing here and obviously that
in that data comes from an uh a country
of origin let's say uh South Africa or
India or some other country and and and
so that information obviously can inform
forecasting efforts for that particular
country for the origin locations where
South Africa or India but our goal is to
see how we could learn something from uh
from this sequencing data in in An
Origin country and then transfer the
data to another location and so
basically there's something that
emerging in South Africa how can we take
that information and forecast uh cases
in other parts of the world not just in
South Africa and so
um so that's basically another part of
the motivation and this is where
hopefully we were going in the future
so
um for this particular presentation
um and some of the things that we've
been doing is characterizing past and
ongoing variant transitions uh we're
also trying to explore the association
between varying transition and
geographic location characteristics you
know demographics and
mitigation strategies in vaccine and all
that to see how that is contributing to
to the spread of um of the variants and
then finally we want to explore
similarities in various Omicron subarian
transitions across locations to see
um how we could potentially learn and
and eventually forecast cases
so here's a summary of some of the data
that we we are
um using and so we basically had to
harmonize this data and so some of the
data comes on on a daily basis and so
it's like static you know such as
population or um Health Systems capacity
or economics that's kind of like a
static
um pictured whether it is provided on a
every 10 years from the Census or it
could be like for economics sometimes
they do uh quarterly kind of updates
um we have obviously clinical
surveillance cases
um and vaccination
information behavioral response and so
this is mandates and then
um data from gizade and so that's the
sequencing data that we're trying to use
and I'll go into a little bit more
detail about the spatial resolution but
basically for some
um in some cases we're able to get it at
the country level and some other cases
we can get it at a more um
final resolution like state level for
example
um so here I just wanted to kind of show
you
um you've probably seen many of these uh
figures of the the different variants I
have
um emerged throughout the pandemic and
so here I just I'm just showing
um some of them and so basically we for
this particular study that I'm going to
be showing right now you know we analyze
over uh 11.5 million
um sequences around the globe and
um and then obviously each of the the
sequences we use the pengul pangolinages
association that you say provides for
each other the sequences to kind of
character um to group all the the
different variants
and so
um here I just wanted to kind of
illustrate
um some of the heterogeneity across
different
um locations and why it is important for
us to really understand
um understand what's going on and how
the landscape and the background is
playing a role because
um as if you see the
um the variants are across the world
then you're going to see many different
uh different kind of
um time series and so here I have four
different countries so India South
Africa Brazil and the United States and
um it probably I don't know if it's if
it's easy or hard to see but you can see
that you know there's clearly
differences between
um India and South Africa for example in
in terms of some of the variants that
emerge early on and you can see that
here in South Africa you have a
significant
um I think it's a beta
um a beta wave whereas in India
um the beta wave was really small and
then here in Brazil we had we see a
gamma wave two and um and we didn't
really see that in the United States or
any other in other parts of the world
and then as we move
um towards the the the end of the x-axis
you can see also a lot of the Omicron
variants that have been uh spreading and
you can see that in the United States
there's
um a lot of also variability in terms of
the variance compared to the other
countries and so
clearly there's differences in timing
magnitude and speed of transitions
um for all the variants and so we are
going to try to see if we can understand
that aspect
so the
um the way many
um
many papers and other people have been
modeling variances basically they just
use a multinomial model and here I'm
just kind of summarizing the model which
is uh here you have the variant uh
proper proportion
and then we have like uh multiple
categories of generalization of the
logistic regression and then this is a
function of time
um so figins and Bedford have a paper
where they use the same approach and
this h of T that I we have here in the
exponent
um they assume that it's a it's linear
in T and
um if you assume the H of i j is linear
um into then
um you have very nice interpretations of
the growth rates
um and so they are able to kind of map
the growth raised to and are not and um
and percent are really in a very
beautiful kind of analysis but um
but the problem with the linearity is
that sometimes the um the fit of the
variance is not very good and I will
show you in just a second uh how that
differs and so
um in our analysis we decided to take a
very you know a very similar approach
when instead of assuming that each of IJ
is going to be linear we decided to make
it more flexible
um and so where you're seeing that
public cubic spline model for um hijt
and
um in this by by changing this
um this assumption it actually gives us
better fit but on the downside is that
we lose the nice interpretation the the
vegans and Bedford actually provided in
their paper and so
um you gain some things and you lose
some others and so here's
um why we decided to kind of change the
the age
um
uh parameter and so you can see here on
the top where our results using um the h
i j
um and assuming that it's linear and so
you can kind of see here that the fits
are not very good uh for for that
particular variant and then you hear you
can kind of see at the beginning of a
pandemic the fits are not and they don't
seem too much very well but um but then
later on I think it it gets better
um but we because we wanted to analyze
all the variants
um that that have emerged then we
decided to just use them more flexible
age um IJ and so you can kind of see
that the fits are better
so now
um so the
given that we have a model and so
so we decided to kind of catch to
summarize the Transitions and of the
variants in using three different
metrics so one is the speed or is the
maximum slope of each
um
um of each variant
um the second summary metric is timing
and so timing of Maximum slope relative
to a global minimum and then finally the
magnitude or this is kind of like
maximum height or prevalence of the of
the variant
um and uh we only model or in summarize
locations with sufficient variant data
and this is and I'll show in just a
second why but this is because not all
the countries are sequencing at the same
rate and so then if you don't have
enough data then it's going to be hard
for us to to fit the model and to have a
more robust kind of solution and so here
I'm kind of showing you all the
locations with sufficient data that we
use so basically we have 215 locations
out of
590 locations and when I say for example
Australia 6 is we are doing Australia in
six
um regions within Australia that are
providing information same for like the
United States we have about you know 51
states also in addition to
um to the country level information
um and so now I'm just going to kind of
jump into each of these different
metrics the speed the timing and the
magnitude or prevalence and then show
you um the differences that we have been
able to capture through this analysis
so here's the speed or this little the
transition and um in this figure you can
see that in the y-axis I have all the
different variants so starting from
alpha you go all the way down to uh
Omicron and then on the x-axis I have
the maximum slope and
um and basically if um farther uh from
the center it's faster transition and
the and and then
um you have the slower transition on on
the the left side and so you can see all
these um
215 regions that or that we have are
kind of spread out across the
um each of the different
um
uh variants and
um I should I should also say that there
were also there may be some
some variants where
um maybe we don't have all their regions
because they didn't have enough data or
because
um that particular variant probably
didn't
um didn't spread very much in certain
regions but um but here if you look at
um at the graph you can see clear
differences across the variants and
um in the speed basically is very
different
um across the
um the world
and um there's a lot of variation
um and um and that we you know we
obviously hypothesize that is because
there is very in competition and
Immunity and that it then that is
contributing to the slope and um and so
here I have also uh we have labeled some
of the um
the countries that were the fastest
um in terms of transition for that
particular
um variant and so that can be
um kind of interesting when we are
trying to transfer this information
and so now
um this is the same information that I
was just showing in the previous slide
but now I have it in maps and so we have
here Alpha Gamma Delta Omicron ba1
Omicron ba11
ba2 and
um the darker the color
um the faster the uh the slope and
um or the speed of transition and then
the lighter
is um the slower the the transition and
so you can clearly kind of see here
um the heterogeneity across the world
for each of the different
um variants that we're analyzing
the question Sarah here it seems like
there is this ba one that has been
raking havoc in Greenland is that true
in Greenland oh and here you mean right
here
um well that's a really good question
Greg
um
uh because I didn't I don't think I saw
Greenland in the list of countries that
we had
um included so I need to go back and
look at why Greenland is
um
people who live in Greenland got
infected at the same time you know and
that was it yeah yeah but I think they
wouldn't I mean if it's only like a
handful because obviously there's not a
lot the population is I don't think it
would have gone through our
um exclusion and inclusion criteria
because it was just
um we are trying to get only locations
that have enough data so that our
analysis are more robust so I'm gonna
I'm I have to look into this and but
thanks Craig for um pointing that out
okay so the next
um
the next metric that we're trying to
capture is uh timing of transition and
um so here we
um you know this it's a very similar
graph as the one that I was showing
earlier but here you know we have on the
y-axis the different variants and on the
x-axis we have timing of Maximum slope
uh relative to the global minimum in
days and so
um
here you can see that this is earlier
transition basically
um in in the the countries that are
labeled which is
um where they were able to
um where the different variants were
able to kind of uh take over
and so you can see um shorter times for
Omicron variants and so
um they're right here
and
um
short times for also some of the MU
Epsilon Iota due to limited uh spread
and so now
um so here's the the same
um well not the same but as as a map of
the timing of transition and I I see
Greenline again ah Greg and so I will
look into that
um and so here you can also see the
relative timing of the maximum slope
um in here
um the the darker means that it was if
the the variants were able to kind of
take over faster uh whereas with the um
the with the lighter one you know it
took longer for for the variants to kind
of take over those regions
um let's see and so then
um the third metric that we
um we've been interested in kind of
characterizing is maximum prevalence and
um here you can it's it's a you know
similar graph you have the
um the different variants and then we
have on the x-axis the maximum variant
prevalence
and so and there's also a lot of
heterogeneity but there's also some kind
of trends that you can uh you can see
and so you can see that beta gamma mu
Epsilon and Iota
um were generally associated with like
lower uh variant prevalence and you can
kind of see them clustered around here
um kind of closer to the left and
um the maximum prevalence how little
heterogeneity across locations uh for
Delta so here's
um the Delta
um variant it was you know quite
um separated from the the other
um the other variants and then then we
have like the omicrons which have been
kind of all over the place
and
um yeah and so now I'm just going to
show you the the map of the maximum
prevalence and so you can also see that
we have all these different
um variants and
um the the prevalence obviously for each
other was very different across the
different um parts of the world
so
um so other things that we've been kind
of trying to
um I mean we've been
um doing different types of analysis to
just see how we are going to be able to
incorporate the sequencing data into
epidemic models and into forecasting
models and so here
um one of the the hypothesis that we or
we had also was what is the impact of
co-circulating variance and how they may
be influencing the the slope or the
magnitude or just the the timing of it
of um of it the variance uh to
transition or to take over and so you
can
um here I have on the x-axis I have the
number of um the the variance basically
you can see Alpha Beta um and also the
number of circulating variants um
you have for
um we kind of cluster them by two three
and four and so those are the different
colors that I'm showing here
um and you can see that a higher number
of circulated variants what's usually
related to lower transition slopes
um so usually the darker ones you can
kind of see that in general the more
variants you have in your region or
um your country
um it's going to be it's going to be
kind of harder for the for the other for
the new variant to kind of take over and
so that's why it's going to be a lower
transition just because
um they're kind of competing for
susceptible people
um and
um and so in that there also what was
kind of interesting is you know you kind
of have all these original variants kind
of cluster around here and then Delta
came and you see a very significant kind
of shift in the the maximum slope and um
just in how they have been kind of
Behaving
um
and so this is um this is some of the
the impact of co-circulating variance so
I think if we
um one of the lessons learned from this
particular analysis is that if there's
too many circulating variants in our
region then then that could tell us
something about the transition and that
that will help our forecasting efforts
um another thing that we wanted to
analyze is what is the impact of
vaccination because we know that
vaccination is going to play a role and
if you have regions that are
have are highly vaccinated maybe they're
um the there's going to be some kind of
differences in how
um how the different uh variants are
actually you know spreading and so you
can so here I have the transition timing
and then here I have the transition
speed
and so you can see that um on the x-axis
I have the people fully vaccinated uh
per 100 000 oh no per 100
um and and then on the y-axis uh on the
first one is the transition timing and
then on the
um the figure on the right is is the um
the transition speed and so you can see
that kind of higher vaccination rates
are associated with lowered um in later
uh variant waves but obviously that
change once Omicron emerged because the
vaccine was only targeted for Delta in
in previous variants then uh then we saw
a reduction in the impact of vaccines in
um in slowing the and the rates the the
speed of the of the transitions and so
um Delta also was the inflection point
and you were able to see that in the
previous video where
um you know most of the variants uh kind
of behave similar and then when Delta
emerge um then we saw very different uh
very different Dynamics and and here in
this analysis you're also uh we're also
seeing that and the way we perform this
these are just pairwise uh Spearman uh
correlation associations that we did for
um for again uh for each of the variants
and then vaccination grades
and so
um we also decided to do some
um to use a random Forest to see
um the the associations and and the
adjusted associations
um for uh variants and all the different
data that we had collected and how
everything is kind of
um working together in terms of the
landscape
um in and interestingly we found the
vaccination Association persisting for
all
um for the transitions I mean for the
maximum slow the timing and also the
prevalence and you can kind of see there
the the
um
uh the driver that had the most impact
was vaccination and that's although in
the bottom and then we have the second
uh most impactful is the number of
course circulating variants
and then
um the next the next one is the
cumulative cases per million and we know
that obviously the number of cumulative
cases per million has something to do
with natural immunity and so this is uh
important so that we know that if we
take those three ingredients into
consideration they will be able to kind
of help us
um I says what how an ovarian will
potentially spread in a new location
and then another
um these are just some coefficient
estimates for um the regression modeling
that we did and so here you can also see
that
um
the the
impact of here is pre-delta vaccinated
Delta vaccinated and Omicron vaccinated
and obviously
um because this is before the new
Omicron vaccine was
um released this analysis um you can see
that the um
the the vaccine has no association in in
impacting Omicron but it does have an
impact
um in in terms of
um reducing uh having a positive
association with uh with Delta and um
and also the pre-delta vaccinated
and so
um okay so here's another some other
kind of analysis that we
um
that we've we've been exploring and
these are just correlations across waves
and here I have Texas and New York and
so
um lots of competition we wanted to kind
of look at Omicron waves just because
that's the the most um current
um
the most growing variant that is
circulating
um and so clearly
um the there's there are clear
differences in these two states even
though they're both in the United States
and but we know that it has to do with
um with the landscape and the number of
people vaccinated and the co-circulated
variants and everything and so what we
did
um notice was the older transitions but
were less relevant and so now that if we
wanted to understand just Omicron that
we needed to just kind of look at the
most recent kind of past uh because that
was going to be more important for um
for the immunity than previous
in previous variants and so
um the last kind of analysis that we we
did is um clustering and so we clustered
locations in terms of Omicron variants
um in transition similarities uh because
we want to start learning what are
um if if different countries have
similar Landscapes if they are having
this a similar outcome basically
so here
um and on the map here you can see kind
of like there's a cluster
um in kind of green orange uh purple
pink and green and
um the Clusters two and three are more
similar and the cluster is four and five
are very uh different and there's you
know there's only there's you have South
Africa and India and
um those two countries are the ones who
have where new variants have emerged and
they seem to have very different kind of
Dynamics
um but then once you once the variances
Start Spreading there are some area
regions that actually seem to be
behaving similarly based on their
landscape and um so here you can kind of
see the United States and
and Canada and there's some also
similarities with Europe and then
there's this uh orange kind of clusters
that we've observed
um
they in the oh yeah this is another
thing which the pre-owned clusters were
very different and so these similarities
will be useful for cross location
forecasting
um especially if um if a new emerging
variant is kind of
um affecting one country we can kind of
use that information to uh inform
another country
and so
um I guess uh some some kind of key
takeaways from from the analysis that
we've been doing and like as I mentioned
we're still kind of in the middle of
this analysis and we haven't really been
able to
um transfer it to forecasting but that's
where we're going
and so we compare different variant
transitions um across the globe and
um we tested a very simple flexible
strategy for modeling many code
circulating variants
um
and uh we identified some associations
between location characteristics and and
variant transitions in particular you
know vaccine closer to living variants
and natural immunities into
um play a role and although intuitively
we knew that I think quantifying it it's
um it's more powerful and so
um we also did some clustering
allowances to see how we can use some of
this um close location uh knowledge
transfer and and because our ultimate
goal obviously is to forecast cases but
we don't want to wait until the the
variant is already emerging
um in the look in the new location and
we want to do it earlier on and so
that's why I think learning from other
countries would be really powerful
and so the next steps obviously are um
to kind of take these relationships uh
that we've been kind of exploring and
assessing for between sequencing in
cases and see how we can
um ultimately forecast cases and so
um this one is kind of just showing
again the division that we have in our
team which is to take variant
information and hopefully
um that could inform uh forecasting
and I think that's all I have
so if you have any questions
um I'm happy to answer questions
that are a fantastic presentation any
questions here oh Greg of course
so Sarah do you have some thoughts about
strategies that you know might be useful
in identifying variants beyond the type
of you know I think reasonable and
straightforward approaches that you guys
have already tried
is there a way to monitor maybe
different parts of the world more
specifically are there any patterns that
you can sort of think of based so for
instance you know we've been talking
about it a little bit yesterday if we
had ability to get perfect data what
would be the type of data that one would
need in order to be able to sort of look
at the kinds of questions that that your
team was looking
so that's a good uh question and so here
is the oh okay there
so here's a map that I feel like would
help me
um answer your question uh Greg and so
there as you know
um there are so many parts around the
globe that are not really doing uh
good at sequencing and the data is very
poor as far as or
um
um sometimes it just you know
I think there are some some a lot of the
sequences that are also submitted
um have errors and so in the way they're
being processed or I don't really know
exactly why there there are many errors
and then eventually you you can't really
use them because they don't really have
all the information and so I think if we
want to really
um we know that variants can emerge
everywhere especially in areas that are
not vaccinated because those areas
um the you know they they're more primed
for
um
for the virus to mutate and develop and
and new variants to emerge and so I
think if we want to
um better modeling forecasts
cases or
um then we need to start collecting
information
um
in all these red areas because we
um we are only uh looking at like a very
small part I guess of what's happening
around the globe and I think that
there's more opportunity for increasing
surveillance systems
maybe I don't know if
um Bill Gates or uh Elon Musk and for
some money and and to increase in
surveillance system but I mean I think
if you look at this map I think it looks
pretty sad
I agree with that and I'm really glad
you made this point Sarah this is this
is excellent the need for large-scale
genomic surveillance the reason we knew
about army crawl was because of the
world-class surveillance genomics
available is done in South Africa we
need a lot more countries to be doing
that I think countries like Germany the
United Kingdom Israel have been doing a
lot of that in South Africa but we need
to do it across the board otherwise
we'll not be able to detect new variants
as they are emergent you know and that's
uh that's a big problem but I have a
question for you uh uh my way okay so if
a new building emerges into your
location was already multiple variants
like when Bobby crowd came Delta was
already in town maybe a few others that
were somewhat suppressed by Delta but uh
you say the likelihood of a new variant
to
to somehow compete and survive uh
is
dependent on how many other causative
variants are but is it also somewhat
dependent on the new variants
transmissibility it's R naught for
example because essentially what's
happening is that they figure out a way
to coexist for this competitive
exclusion
so is it related so much if you
calculate the r naught for each of the
variants you compare them uh is it
likely that the one that has higher or
not will definitely display the other so
is so the data shows that
maybe either is the data showing that's
some kind of hierarchical uh likelihood
of New Village displays in others based
on bits are not always or it's
transmission transmission capacity
so I yeah I do think that they're
um let's see if I can I think I've had
um
maybe here that um
you do see
um I think that the variants obviously
that have more
um
that have are are better able to spread
obviously I think will be the one to win
but you still see
um so for example if we if I take here
uh March 22nd you see these two
um kind of variants kind of crossing and
so there's significant like spread for
both of those variants at the same time
and obviously this very end is kind of
coming down and the other one is taking
off but um I don't know I feel like that
the
the previous uh belief that we had in
the modeling community that you know
always one will
um
emerge the Victorious or the one is the
one to to to spread more I think that
that
um it it does work in some cases but I
feel like covid-19 has shown us that
things can change very differently and I
mean I think there's so many things that
we learned from covid-19 in one of them
is I feel like you can have like
um here two kind of variants taken uh
over like this kind of dark blue and
another even darker blue they're both
like
spreading almost you know simultaneously
and you don't really have one with I
mean even I don't know what they are not
what's for for these two but that they
they both somehow can coexist and
survive and and spread and so
um so I'm not sure that I'm answering
your question about but I feel like that
there's
there's a lot more that we need to dig
in to understand you answered my
question actually I was motivated by a
paper we wrote a long time ago on
multiple strains was said you may
remember I signed paper where you had
the coexistence and competitive rest
Solutions that's what kept in mind when
I've seen this
any more questions yes
thank you very much for your excellent
talk so in fact I have two questions my
first question is you talk about
sequencing at the beginning of your talk
and finally I have the impression that
sequencing only served to identify
violence but you have other information
of sequencing for instance sometimes
phyogenetic trees if they are available
they can give also information on on
transmission rates and speed of
transition
and my second question is uh everything
seems to be model free because also you
did restoring Etc but
um to to fulfill the program that you
have given are you going to somehow use
some of that at some point
um the purpose was really to remain
modem free and just use the data methods
from data Sciences
yeah so okay let me answer your first
question
um about the sequences and you know
there's all this like phylogenetic tree
analysis that the immunologies are
working on and so some of our um some of
the people in my team are
um people that work with sequences and
are immunologists and so they understand
that and so we are looking at some of
that information but for this particular
analysis we didn't really look at the
um annual information that came from the
trees we just kind of decided to explore
it from a more you know used in like the
multinomial model approach
um I think eventually so our goal is to
eventually have a model and so when we
start modeling the spread when we
transitioned to cases we will have you
know the traditional models that are Sie
are type approaches
um one of some of the models that we've
developed in the past are inspired by
the siei sir type model but they uh we
typically use ibasian models just um
based in hierarchical models just
because we are forecasting and not just
necessarily doing scenario projection
um
in those models you can incorporate you
know the beta and behavior and vaccine
and so they do kind of are more
mechanistic in nature and so our goal is
to move to the model and mechanistic
type approaches and I just stay within
this multinomial which is a very
simplistic way to
um assess the sequences and I think once
we start going into the modeling I think
we will be kind of Might maybe teasing
out a little bit more information from
the immunologist about
um
identifiability because you know if you
have I it's
um for example a Siberian more
transmissible just because it's it's you
know it's more transmissible or is it or
uh because the vaccine maybe is not
working against it or in vice versa and
so we will probably have to get more
information from the people that are
doing more of the analyzing the
sequences and figuring out how the
mutations
um contribute to the spread or
contribute to
um vaccine
um
avoidance and that kind of stuff so I I
hope I answer your question
yes thank you very much
uh Sarah I'm Jorge Velasco thank you for
YouTube hi
um I have a question on your first map
the well you have 215 uh
right that that's a very very
interesting map
um uh one of the things that I think are
very interesting these days is that this
founder is between this green and the
red countries because that identifies in
this map lack of data but probably this
lack of data is also indicative of
different ways of dealing with the
pandemic right in terms of oh yeah yes
you control the sampling and all the
things vaccination and stuff and so I
wonder for example the border between
Mexico and the United States that is a
very interesting interface it's a it's a
it's a it's a territory in which you
have two different
impacts of measurements intensity of
measurements and probably this is
playing a role in the variance the the
changes in the variants that we have the
speed at which they grow when they grow
and uh the impact that vaccination has
for this on this particular
interfaces because uh as as we mentioned
barriers may may arise in this interface
area so I wonder if you have more
specific data or have some emphasis
significantly On the Border regions in
the world the Mexico United States a
clear one very close to us but in in
this map you can see several of them
that are very important uh because of
precisely this inequality in the way uh
the disease is being treated so I wonder
if you have some information or ideas on
on what is happening there thank you
hi Jorge um that's a really good
question and I actually don't have data
but I feel like that's something that I
would want to pursue because it's such a
I feel like that's a low-hanging fruit
that we could utilize to
um hopefully persuade people to collect
more data but I think that those
um those border regions and you know and
as you mentioned it like you you can see
them all over the world
um it would be very important and
perhaps
um you may be able to capture some
information even if you don't have so
I'm so I'm thinking like at the border
of Mexico that we may be able to capture
some of that
um because of the connectivity with the
with the South uh with the southern part
of the United States
and maybe we can inform what's happening
um on the other side of the Border by by
surveilling you know like in the South
so I think that that's an interesting uh
idea that um that we can kind of take a
look at and and see if we can do
something about that
and similar also too
similar also to look at Southern Africa
there that's next door to Malawi
Botswana and so on the bread and so you
know so yeah that's I think that's very
good but but Christian has a question
okay I saw this question box I have sort
of a more
Global profession so how far are we from
a dream that so we saw let's say omicon
appear in South Africa and then people
said okay it will appear in Europe soon
and maybe in the us but we were not
really good at predicting it or let's
say we saw that BF4 and 5 are really
taking off at Italy in the summer and
how far are we from saying well given
the data we have and the data about the
post biological data your sequencing
data and maybe some surveillance data we
have in New York and California
how far are we from predicting oh it
probably will in New York sort of Peak
at a certain number a month later and in
California I won't pick that much so is
there do we have any hope that at some
point we are good in this kind of
forecasting or not
um well that's what we're trying so I I
hope that we will get there and
um given so our hypothesis and that we
hope to to prove is that by
understanding the landscape we will be
able to say
um this is the level of uh this is the
prevalence that you're going to see in
New York this is uh how fast it may take
over from the current variant and these
are you know cases and everything and so
we are hopeful
um the the one thing that worries me uh
is that surveillance
systems are kind of slowly dying now
because people are just
too tired of covid-19 and and so if if
we don't continue to sequence and to
kind of track cases we're not really
going to be able to
um validate our models and see if
they're accurate and so if we can't
validate the model then it's it's going
to be hard for us to
to you know believe in them and and have
um
you have robust Solutions and so if we
continue to take um collect data and
good data I think that we could
eventually get there but um I don't know
exactly when I I I hope soon but I don't
know
so so you would think if sort of this
dies down at some point in five years we
get a worse
new epidemic we might actually be there
that we can predict
I I mean I I think for at least for
covid-19 I feel like we have a path
forward I don't know
um if for other diseases
um we will have a path or the one the
other also uh ingredient which is very
important in that
it's Behavior human behavior and right
now we're not really collecting a lot of
human behavior there's no like
centralized databases
uh collecting human behavior and so
unlike you know we've been always
um comparing disease forecasting with
weather forecasting and the the benefit
of weather forecasting is that it the
weather doesn't care and if you bring an
umbrella or not about for for infectious
diseases it does our Behavior plays a
big role and so not not just
understanding the landscape in terms of
the immunity and co-circulated variants
but also if we don't have a good
assessment of behavior then that's also
going to limit our ability to forecast
accurately I think we can forecast
something but I don't know how accurate
those forecasts might be and so I think
there's I think we may be able to do to
kind of move the field forward I don't
know that it's going to be a hundred
percent
let me ask this special difference a few
of us have been sitting broadcaster and
asking can we sort of
look check and see where what would we
need and tools for the next epidemic
right so what
why didn't we do that well for covert in
the beginning and what would we want the
scientific Community to develop in the
next
few years so that we better equip that
one of the things you're mentioning is
probably better implementing you with
behavior in some way into our models I
mean your sreer model
you want to fit this tool you didn't
talk about seir class behavior model
which we probably need right oh yeah
yeah yeah
I a hundred percent and I so I think we
need more comp models that are
um
have are able to capture the complexity
of the real world and one of them is
behavior we also most of our model
didn't incorporate sequencing and or you
know these different variants there's
been some models with like multiple
strains it's usually like two and now
we're in this landscape where we have
like you know I don't know 20 things
spreading at the same time and so yeah
we definitely need models that are have
they are able to capture the complex
dynamics that we're living in
and also obviously there's so many other
things about communication and maybe
like consistency of
um mitigation strategies as you know in
the US you know like Texas was doing one
thing you know Mexico was doing another
thing and we're like right next to each
other and I think when you have
um policies that are very different and
and that they have you have these
borders and people are moving back and
forth I think that it just I think it
was a
it was a recipe for a disaster I guess
and so that's why we struggle a lot with
um not having kind of consistent
policies that would benefit
um the public health I agree with that
Sarah
I agree with completely with that so
yesterday I think that one themes of
yesterday's sessions here at this
Workshop was Behavior information
diffusion and all that stuff we had a
really good discussion on on all of this
how to incorporate human behavior and
information diffusion what kind of
algorithms and models
have been used and also the policy issue
we mentioned that's that's great we've
talked about meta population models for
example and different states different
jurisdictions have different policies uh
sometimes that could be very detrimental
controls but anyway thank you so very
much any more questions before we expect
Sarah one more time for a fantastic talk
very nice thank you so much Sarah for
really excellent work
thank you ABBA thank you everyone okay
thank you bye-bye all right
[Applause]
[Music]
very quietly